most
addictions thrive in secrecy that's it
i'm telling you it's the secret is the
killer
when i started the voice that i had an
addiction i started to voice what the
pornography thing was and i start to
talk it loses its power
shame can't survive the light it can't
it's like exposing the germs to sunlight
that's one reason why i'm so vulnerable
because i don't want any secrets i tell
the whole story and man i'm in control
hey everybody welcome to the podcast
today we're going to talk about strength
we're going to talk about power but not
the physical kind i'm talking about the
mental and emotional kind
it's a conversation about masculinity
both toxic and healthy it's about
overcoming obstacles how to confront
your past own your path and ultimately
step into your truest power and most
self-actualized self our guide for this
journey is former nfl linebacker
lifelong artist and star of screens big
and small
terry crews you know this guy you may
know him from idiocracy
the expendables movies brooklyn
nine-nine everyone hates chris
america's got talent or one of his many
other projects
you're also likely familiar with terry's
insane physique his incredible charm but
beneath it all is actually a guy who's
endured a litany of uncommon hardships
and really struggled immensely for the
better part of his life to
control his relationships his image as a
tough guy
his experiences with racism
all of which led to this destructive
spiral that he endured and ultimately a
path forward a path that has
given him a new perspective and and
really a new life all of which is
elegantly and powerfully chronicled in
his new book out this week entitled
tough my journey true power
today we cover it all
and in addition to just being an
incredible human and a powerful
storyteller
terry was remarkably frank he was
very generous with this time and
this conversation is just fantastic so
please click that subscribe button and
hit that notification bell and let's do
it this is me and terry crews
well you got a lot going on um i
appreciate you taking the time to do
this especially on saturday man i'm
excited for you the new book is coming
out lots to talk about
and
you know to kind of kick things off
um
i was thinking about how to approach
this conversation with you and thinking
about what this show is about and you
know i talk to lots of different people
across you know a multiplicity of
specialties and expertise but if there
is one kind of core theme it's
it's transformation like how do you
weather obstacles how do you persevere
and grow and
evolve and share what you learned along
the way like in service to other people
and as much as anybody that i know
you truly embody this ethos not just you
know in the many pivots across the
course of your life and the many
challenges that you faced and overcome
but this you know this transparency uh
that you have around
expansion into self authenticity um and
how you show up in the world in service
is is really the heart of kind of what i
love to talk about and what you're all
about so i'm really excited to talk to
you today thank you thank you so why
don't we start with
you know the subject matter of of the
book which is really
this um journey from
what we could kind of i mean this term
has played out toxic masculinity but
this journey from you know
being sort of the embodiment of toxic
masculinity to this
um
to this you know person who who could be
characterized as as very much
self-actualized in many ways i mean
we're all on our journey we all there's
always the more you grow the more you
realize how much more there is to grow
that's right but why don't we start
there and and you know maybe
talk a little bit about um
about masculinity and how you're
thinking about it yeah you know um and
you're right uh in in the regard that
the phrase toxic masculinity has been
played out it's just
right now it's been so overused and
misrepresented and all this stuff but
now the phrase that i like to use is
abuse of power
and
you know
one thing for me
you know in growing up and where and my
to give you some context and some
background is that you know i i grew up
in flint michigan
uh
in 1968 that was when i was born and you
know flint michigan was palo alto it was
the premier
young vibrant city general motors was
the number one corporation in the world
it was the google of its generation so
everyone was was doing very very well
and they made a lot of promises a lot of
promises to the citizens um
to the families and i mean you could go
there my father moved up from a little
town in edison georgia
uh that was only 300 people and he moved
up to to join the factory like most of
my family did
on both sides from my mom's side and my
father's side they all came up from
georgia because of the promise of all
these jobs and all this stuff and and so
there was a lot of hope there was i mean
my early early days it was it seemed
like the city was growing and big events
and all this stuff and
and then all of a sudden um when i
turned around nine or ten um
on the you know the late 70s things
started to change and i mean very very
quickly
and
um
you know
this this
the whole the auto industry was going
down
the
you know
everything the the foreign cars started
to come into into play into the picture
and a lot of people don't remember this
but i do um there used to be like small
smoke smoke stacks going up around the
city and what they were doing was
burning foreign cars in
the lots like if you brought a toyota
into the city
and people would surround it and burn it
in effigy wow
so i know you know i know that vibe like
you you ain't driving a foreign car you
remember that yeah i think it's i think
it's still that way in detroit oh yeah
it's wild i didn't see a foreign car
until i joined the nfl and moved out to
la and i was like that's a mercedes
wow like that's a bmw you know what i
mean because it was just for it was
crazy um
but on top of this on top of these small
changes that were happening there was
things going on in my house
my father
was extremely abusive um one of my
earliest memories like when i was four
or five years old
i remember my father
knocking my mother out you know
right there in the living room
and
i can't describe the helplessness i felt
because you know um my father was a
giant i mean he had these big giant my
hands are big but he had these big
callous
giant man hands and he would walk around
the house with this boom
you know the way he walked and the way
he moved and the way he did everything
it was just
it was like watching a giant in this
force
and
when when he would hit my mother and i
saw her on the ground
i was like got it
that's the rules
we run it
men run it
and
this is the lesson i had that's in
regards to masculinity it was like yo
you control everything
um he controlled our household um it
wasn't a thing where
you know i felt the love of my father
but i felt the possessiveness of my
father i felt
like a
something he owned um
and he owned his family and it was a and
he made sure that we it was a little bit
for him he'd rather be feared than loved
you know and
he never really gave any
bit of
he never really showed any any what
would be called vulnerability
it was always solid hardcore
this is the way i am this is you know
everything was military-like
and brutal in judgment you know um
which it was i mean i i literally i
remember just holding my breath
around on top of that you have the
alcoholism and you talk about in the
book the morning dad and the night dad
yes trying to connect with your dad in
the morning but that fear when he would
pull up in the driveway at night not
knowing what you were going to get and
all of that but i also appreciated in
the book how
you painted a broader picture of who
this man was rather than just
um kind of characterize him as the abuse
of alcoholic this was a guy who like
despite everything would put himself
together in the morning would polish his
shoes was trying to find some modicum of
pride in this factory job that he had
and and this idea that a lot of the you
know quote unquote toxic masculinity
aspects of of who he was were were
driven by a sense of powerlessness when
the factories were drying up and the
jobs were going away and all of that
like it's more nuanced than just saying
he was a b and c exactly and listen the
thing is my dad made it
like
from where he came from
it was a thing where wow
like he was a symbol of pride
um it was everyone who was back home was
like man you did it
um his father once i got into my past
and i learned and it took me listen
in the course of writing this book i
found out more about
my past than i ever knew in my 54 years
on earth right that's
that's maybe my favorite part of the
whole book when you trace that later in
the book it's so special it's so amazing
because but you know one thing i learned
is his father
you know was on a chain gang in georgia
in the heat and 100 degree humidity of
georgia
he committed a few crimes and was
convicted to
you know serving on a chain gang and he
as a child had to pass
his own dad and
on the school bus to watch knowing that
his dad was out there
tied to other prisoners working on the
roads
and i'm like these are the kind of
things that would drive a man to drink
yeah you know i mean these are the kind
of that's the kind of pain
that he could never articulate that he
couldn't understand and his father died
at 17 years when he was 17 years old
and he never got over it you know um
because his father basically abandoned
the family and so when you're talking
about this kind of deep deep thing and
this is another thing
um
and i got in trouble a little bit about
this you know early on especially on the
internet but
you know my my dad needed his father
and a lot of times you know i know my
purpose on earth you know and
but what's wild is that i've had people
tell me that fatherhood is not necessary
and i'm i'm going
but you wouldn't say that about
motherhood you know
uh and i'm telling you from my own
personal experience i needed my dad
and
they go well no you know that if two
parents love each other it's all good
and then what was happening is uh
especially in the black community you
know the issue of you know there being
no fathers
is directly tied in to a lot of the
problems that the community has i mean
you know black men are six percent of
the american population
yet make up more than 40
of the homicide victims
which is unreal which is a problem which
is what you would call a catastrophe
um
and
i think there are parallels to the fact
that
the the fatherlessness
in that community in our community
it ties into the violence it ties into
when you don't have a dad around you you
go right to the gangs you go right to
those vices you go right to all those
things because you do need
you need someone to guide you um
to show you what being a man is is like
and when we're talking about masculinity
right and also the question the the
epigenetics of generation after
generation repeating you know
like sort of patterns that don't work
and kind of calcifying this idea of what
it means to be a man because they're
repeating the patterns of their father
even if that that father was present in
the household like in your case
who was your who was your model for how
to be a man in the world it was a guy
who was completely locked down
emotionally that's right um but i
appreciated the
attempt to try to understand him as a
guy who was also
caught between the white world and the
black world like he was too advanced in
the factory
to be accepted by you know the guys on
the floor right who are predominantly
black but he wasn't quite in the c-suite
to be accepted by the white guy so he
had his own like kind of identity crisis
that he was trying to navigate
simultaneously you know a lot of people
just
what is really really
hardcore
in his walk was that here he was he was
trying to make it and he felt like he
was doing
uh the right thing
and then what was crazy is that he was
ridiculed by his peers um just for
advancing mm-hmm which is another
problem you know and and then when you
advance
the people who you know
kind of hold the key to your future
wouldn't accept him completely simply
because he was one of the few black
foreman
in
in the play so you had tons of white
foreman all around and they would go on
up the ladder
he being a black foreman
uh kind of was stuck in his place
because he wouldn't he wouldn't get
invited to the inner city i mean the
inner party right in her sector you know
what i mean and then the blacks who were
on the floor was just like oh he's a
sell-out um
and what's wild is that there's a you
know there's a phrase that blacks use
you know to describe what they would
call you know people who sell black
people who sell out and it's a [ __ ]
and they look at you capitulating to
you know the white world in order to be
accepted
uh and what you're doing you know you're
doing what you have to do to make it
um
and that's a hard road and he took these
things personally
and i'm a good thing is i'm smart enough
and have learned enough to know to let
that just you know
for me
you know these kind of insults are just
like okay that has more to do with you
than it does with me
but back in that in that time and that
period there wasn't that kind of
introspection you know i mean it was
just like why uh why am i not being
accepted by my own people you know right
and he was very angry like right it just
created this really toxic anger so you
have this unhealthy role model in the
household meanwhile
the jobs are drying up there's white
flight the gangs are coming in so you go
to school and you went to flint academy
which was like kind of the best place
for you to go right but
um not a lot of great role models there
either right a lot of temptations i mean
you could have easily like there's so
many inflection points in your story and
in your life i mean you could have
easily gone down a dark alley with the
whole gang thing yeah yeah i mean
i i have because now on the flip side um
my mother was extremely religious
which is a whole nother right aspect
yeah that's a whole other section of the
book it's right i mean i i we we deal on
all these topics and i kind of was
right in the middle of all this stuff
with the religion you know i was not
able
allowed to go to secular movies listen
to secular music
go um dance
go to uh play sports i was everything i
ended up doing and being in my life i
was not allowed to do as a kid but we're
about the same age so we both remember
well that first experience of going to
star wars yeah and for you that was like
this transgressive act listen i begged
my mother was not going to let us go um
the the religion that we were in was
it was it was so
strict and so
shame-based and everything was just
you know you you the thing is you could
go to hell
at any moment that was the the through
line like anything was send you to hell
okay so
going to a movie oh no you're going to
go to hell you do that you know and i
begged my mother and she wouldn't let me
joe and we were just like i couldn't
because you go to school and you hear
people talking this is days when a movie
was four-walled so a movie would be in
the theaters for a year right you know
like now it's like it's out in three
weeks you know i mean but it would be in
the movie for a year two years and it
would be and still be out and i would
hear the kids in school just
oh star wars and he'd be talking about
different parts and i'm like oh my god i
just gotta see this and the anticipation
and the and then just i just wanted to
see it so bad at my aunt thank god she
came through
and she said my mother's name was
patricia she said trish you gotta let
these kids see this movie you know like
i'm gonna take them okay is it can i
take them
and she
just broke like
all right go ahead i said and it changed
my life forever i'll never forget that
driving in seeing stuff watching that we
all remember that john williams scoring
hit god you know what i mean it was it
so how does your mom square like what
you're doing now with that like mindset
well my mom passed away uh 2015. um but
she also
she was alive long enough to yeah she
left the church she left that version of
what the church was um when i was
probably in high school and
she went to a less restrictive version
of of christianity um but i like to call
it a cult i mean it was it was very
cultish in all its ways i mean when
you're talking about rules and
and all this stuff so she kind of moved
on from that
and grew into loving what i was doing um
you know
what's wild is that she kind of saw the
light as we moved on and and i got more
popular and started doing things she
started to understand
but she
you know
she was she loved what i did at the end
one one thing is she always always loved
entertainment like always mm-hmm and she
had the
subscriptions to all the magazines
exactly people magazine and all that
kind of stuff well i i worked hard to
rectify
like to try to
figure out what that was like we can't
go to the movies but we love the movies
we can't do this but we love this and it
was so i used to read her people and
entertainment magazines and the whole
thing and one thing we did together
though
was we would sit and watch the carol
burnett show
i'll never forget every saturday night
and it was the highlight highlight of my
life because
first of all
you know my i'll never forget my mom
was nursing a black eye that my daddy
gave her and she had like this
it was some frozen peas or something on
her eye
and we would just sit and watch caroline
and laugh and laugh and then after it
was over i would repeat some of the
skits and and she would just laugh at me
doing
some of the skits the tim conway and
harvey corman and all that stuff and
i'll never forget that uh i mean even to
this day
i view that as my first step
in what i'm doing now um was the attempt
to make my mother laugh through all the
pain she was going through well there's
this split in who you are for the better
part of your life like on the one hand
you're this alpha athlete who guy is
going in the weight room trying to get
big and strong to deal with what's going
on at home and to deal with the sort of
social stratification of school
but at the same time you're a kid who's
sensitive and likes comic books and is
really good at drawing and art
which
you know creates this tension in like
who am i who is terry crews and how am i
showing up in the world like these two
things kind of at war with each other it
was at war and
what was wild is that um
you know i remember
you know having to fight my way into
school it was you know
the gangs the drug dealers
the the the people that were around me
were always looking at me suspiciously
um they would say things like you talk
white
you know
and i'm like what is that
um
and what was happening is remember i was
kind of sheltered is what it was i mean
i was religious and i was in this thing
where it wouldn't allow us to do
anything but so i would go into my hole
and i would draw and draw all day i mean
i would draw what i wanted to see
you know and it was an introspective
very nerd nerdy world i became this nerd
but then when i came outside
i was always challenged on it like oh
man you this you know back in back in
the day they called you a square you
know and it was like what and but then
athletics coded black
coded hardcore
so i said all right
so i have to be that
you know and i knew
that i had to be big strong fast
athletic
and they would leave me alone you know
it's like i knew when i got some traps
that they they think twice about they go
well
he's probably going to do some athletic
stuff so they leave him alone but the
skinny kid
he had no hair no no choice they would
beat him up it would be crazy it would
be violent they used to beat up my
brother he was he was smaller than i was
he's my half brother
and i remember these gang members threw
this threw him in the rose bush and
he was just
hurt and we went home and he was in
tears and i was just like pulling him
out of it like
but they didn't mess with me yeah um but
that coded black and it coded hardcore
you know what i mean but it's almost
like this shield this armor that you
built around yourself simply to protect
that artist within you yeah so he could
still you know do his thing quietly
without you know being bullied or
taking a task i always knew
that i was what you would call weird you
know in that respect because it people
were always you they would just tell me
man you weird man you know and i'm hey
you know whatever i don't i would just
kind of blink it off and but and this is
another thing is that i would
i would fake it
you know a lot of my acting ability
you know
one thing i used to do is dumb down it
was oh man i don't know what y'all
talking about man what you doing man
yeah you know you know and you just
learned to mirror the lingo and the
mirror i would mirror people
so that they wouldn't be suspicious you
know like just get along to go along it
was get and then go home and then all of
a sudden find somebody who
uh or or even be at school and and find
somebody who had we had the same you
know interest and it was like oh man i
could go all in on this you know what i
mean um
and it was funny because even when i met
my wife
she said
he said i thought you were the biggest
nerd and i saw you with your friend
and you talked a whole different way and
i was like ah that's that's kind of how
i've been doing my whole life you know i
knew because she was like you were
you're here i'm thinking you're this
nerdy black guy and then i turn around
and you're with this you're you're these
guys your friends and you're talking all
cool and i was like just like two people
and i was like yeah
this had to be that way my whole life
but this this idea blossoms into this
notion that
that this is the case for all men
doesn't don't all men have two lives the
secret life that they hide from
everybody else and then the way that
they show up in the world that's right
that's just the way it is it is i
believe that i believe that that was
definitely the case for me yeah
so
uh without any kind of healthy role
models for yourself as a young person
you strike this vow with your friend
which i think is super interesting it's
it's almost like a survival tactic like
hey no one's showing us the way like we
got to help each other out yeah i mean i
i remember coming to my friend a good my
best friend in the world his name was
darwin
and i said hey man
i said dude no one how no one is telling
us anything and we had nothing but
questions and we would try we would ask
and the men wouldn't give it up they
would they would literally you're gonna
find out
hey let me tell you something you're
gonna find out on me you know and you're
like oh man what
and it's like dude i'm i'm i'm 11. can
you please just give me some clues and
then
what was wild is that we would get all
this erroneous information like what the
things they did volunteer was like hey
man look what you want to do you want to
take these like these girls tell them
you love them
get the draws
and then bounce and i was like but
what if you do like them no no you don't
love them you can't love them and you're
like what are you talking about like it
did because i had this vision of
actual love like
i mean at the picture like even in the
movies like there's people falling in
love though right and like nah man what
you want to do you got to have like four
or five and you got to keep them on and
you got to always keep them on the leash
and then call them and then don't call
them back i mean and the whole phrase
was called game
and it's still talked about even now you
know uh
and it was like you gotta have game to
run this thing and then you can have all
these girls you can you gotta have ten
and the more you had the more of a man
you were
and i was like and that's again the
message of what masculinity was
was that you were a pimp
and that's what i grew up with and it
was like but i said but i don't
i just you know and i had a really
really hard time because i said i don't
really want to lie to people
but
and then i escaped into porn
and i was the only because my parents
nev my father to this day has never had
a conversation with me about sex ever
and my mother
was so religious she was like i was she
she was like you have sex and i'm like
no oh no i'm not don't don't do it i'm
trying listen you know you go to hell
right yeah okay back to hell again
you know um and so i've totally avoided
that conversation
but so everything i learned was at nine
years old when i went over my uncle's
house opened up his chest and it was
full of pornographic magazines and you
know a lot of people you know what's
wild about that is that everybody says
well you know uh pornography is great
you know when people it's totally
acceptable when people are over 18 the
whole thing but i don't know anybody
that ever encountered pornography at 18.
no
i yeah you know you always encounter it
in school or whatever someone's showing
you and you're like six seven eight nine
i mean yeah and it's damaging it's
damaging it really is and we you know we
grew up in a time where it was you know
in a box that that your friend's dad had
in the basement somewhere or buried in
the woods or some [ __ ] like that you
know and now it's like ubiquitous and
so readily available and unlimited and
it's [ __ ] crazy i can't listen man
the thought of what kids are possibly
looking at right now
it's just since chills down my back yeah
chills and
because i know what's what path it set
me on um
and again man
you know people have said well
you can't i don't think you can be
addicted to pornography and the whole
thing but but my problem was is that hey
man if day turns in the night
and you're still watching it
and you say you don't want to and you
keep doing it
i don't know what else to call it um and
but i found even as a young kid what
happened is when i discovered it it took
all my problems away
i mean i was when i opened that magazine
i didn't even know what i was looking at
mind you i didn't even know how to have
sex
but i just knew oh my god this is
mind-blowing you know and i was totally
numbed out and i forgot about the
violence i forgot about my dad and i
forgot about the religiosity and then
what would happen is i would get shame
and you feel like oh lord i know i'm
going to hell i'm going to hell and so
you would say i'll be good i'll be good
and i became a performer
i became this person
who wanted to keep peace in the house i
was going to be the best most christian
kid
and i was going to be the best most
great kid for my dad you know and do
whatever he says right
um
and it just
but i had no say of my own like
what i wanted was always the fourth
thing down the line you know what i mean
and i was taught that like literally
like it don't matter what you want you
know you better listen to what we're
saying you better listen to what's going
on here and so the neighborhood cat
pulled
the gangs had pulled my parents had
pulled but i had no voice right and
you're just trying to keep the peace and
keep everyone else happy i mean it's
classic child of alcoholic stuff and
what's what's interesting about your
story is like you've never you don't
you've never drank right like you saw
your dad you're like i don't want that
you don't do drugs
but you know maybe you got the gene and
it just got expressed through
porn right and it was that way i mean
alcohol would have served a similar
purpose just numbing the pain and
allowing you to escape but then creating
you know external circumstances that
weren't so good which leads to that
shame spiral but ultimately because
you're not dealing with what's causing
that internal pain you're always going
to go back to it that's right i mean
i mean i i shudder to think had i been
involved with gambling
um i just i go oh my god like i would
have been i tell him if i had ever been
like a drug dealer i would have been the
worst i i you know i'd have been nino
brown i'd have been you know i mean i
i'd have been tony montana and it would
have been
i just do everything
to that level you know what i mean like
it's very extreme
i didn't even go to a football player in
school i ended up in the nfl you know
what i mean it's just a very very crazy
story in and of itself yeah i i i'm
[ __ ] i'm just
i have no
what i say i go 100 and and
i have no half speed button you know
what i'm saying it's kind of like i'm
either all in or i'm out
and that's the way it's been
but it happened like it works for me
when it's a good thing and when it's a
bad thing oh my god right it can tear up
everything
prophets walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share
those that we don't know who can teach
us something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper
voicing change is a physical
manifestation of the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts
essays and stunning photography making
for an exquisite companion to the first
volume
or a satisfying stand-alone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits
and physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained within
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
well i want to put a pin in the whole
pornography thing and return to that
because i want to talk about the
recovery piece there but as we're
working our way through the story you
make this pact with your friend darwin
you're gonna tell each other what you
find out in the world but you do have
like there are a couple mentors who show
up you have this teacher
at flynn academy who kind of changes
your life he does um
first of all there were two people um
one was a coach and one was a teacher my
teacher was my uh
art teacher named mr eichelberg
and
he believed in me when i didn't believe
in myself you have to understand like
for me uh especially in michigan there
are two michigans there's like the white
michigan there's the ann arbor yeah um
i'm from the white michigan yeah you
know what i mean it's traverse city it's
gorgeous it's pretty they're by the
water and then there's detroit and
there's benton harbor there's flint
there's muskegon you know i mean cities
like that and what happens is um
i didn't i remember
people talking about the cranbrook
academy about you know yeah it wasn't
there were no black people there you
know i mean not when i was a kid it
wasn't but cranbrook is like the epic
private school in like kind of near
gross point exactly yeah and it's very
white very it has this incredible arts
program oh incredible yeah
beyond belief and i uh but i said
i'm not going there like that's not
going to be me i
i couldn't see your way in right
and uh but i love to draw and i just was
i loved doing my thing and mr eichelberg
looked at me and he he literally grabbed
all my stuff he said terry
he said this is the best work i've ever
seen
he's like hey man you i'm the teacher
and you're better than me you could
teach the course how old were you at the
time oh i was uh shoot in 10th grade i
was probably in 10th grade 14 years old
and he said man
you uh you said you have tremendous
talent and i was like
thanks thanks and what i would do
um is
back in the day you know when the drug
dealers took over i mean all the crack
epidemic was hitting hard it was like
through the 80s and then hip-hop was
coming along with it so what i would do
is i would make all these sketches of
like
mickey mouse as a drug dealer you know
uh this kind of stuff and they would
print t-shirts
and i was like i would get 25 for a
t-shirt my t-shirt would be all around
the city because everybody grabbed it
and you see him he's have the cell phone
and the you know all the stuff and the
accoutrements to feel you know the fila
shoes the nikes and you kind of
ghettoize
these characters and that was one thing
that i did to make money
and kind of do that and i thought that's
the pinnacle like that's all the arts
going to be doing for me
he took my art
photographed it
basically put it all into applications
to all these places and got me a
scholarship to interlochen arts academy
which is one of the most prestigious
arts academies in the world like larry
page founder of google went there along
amongst everybody jewel went there
i've been there it's incredible it's
incredible yeah it's
it's life-changing and
i he said terry he came up to me and
said terry i i he said i want to i want
to give i got something to tell you
and i was like what do you mean he said
i got an announcement i got you a
scholarship
one to interlochen and to western
michigan university
because he had by that time i was around
as right before my senior year and he
had got all that stuff for
you know
did it for you and did it
and i didn't even i didn't even know wow
and he was like that's how good i
believe you are man and you got it
and i just shook like
what in the world and i it changed my
life dude
to this day
it changed my i remember when i go it
went to interlochen
out of about 500 people 500 kids that
were there for that summer session it
was about six black kids you know and so
and i was part of the arts department
and the arts program and so they they
had this um curator from the university
of cincinnati come and i had drunk they
said they were big on competition so
they were like draw two
drawings and put it on the board but
don't put your name on it so i put it on
the board and it was amongst this whole
wall full of everyone's drawings right
and they asked the curator
which one was the best
and he went all the way around the room
and he said that one
and it was mine
and then he said so what's the next best
he went all the way around around the
room and went to my other one
and that's when it hit me the moment it
hit me and people were clapping and they
were like that's terry
and that's when i realized wow like i am
i'm as good as anybody like it because i
didn't believe it you know i was told
but that was a moment i was like there
is something here like that this is
special this is something that i can
count on like this is this is something
i i have to invest in you know
and it changed my my trajectory because
again i spent so much time hiding my art
i spent so much time trying not to be a
nerd you know it was like
trying not to be that guy because i
would get super excited but oh man i got
these ideas a minute and they look at me
like
all right like who do you think you are
and i was like okay let me just all
right
don't worry about it you know yeah even
coming from like uh who do you think you
are a culture too like don't get so high
on your own supplies totally so i mean
you have to understand even my family
members were like who do you think you
are
relax
my father straight up to hey man the
white man only going to let you go so
far
that was his that would you could put
that on a t-shirt you could have that as
a mantra you know we might as well put
that in a frame that was his lived
experience that's it white man's only
going to let you get so far
so stop asking
like literally stop
and i just couldn't stop after i had
that interlocking experience
and i saw what i could do i said i'm not
going to stop
i'm not going to stop asking so you end
up at western michigan you get this
scholarship an art scholarship to go
there
the question then becomes like why
didn't you just go full in on the art
thing and instead you're like i'm going
to play football because it was only 500
okay
now understand
you could go to college back in 19
what in 1987 you could go to college for
three thousand dollars
you could and you could work and go to
college and for three grand you would
pay all your tuition do your whole thing
um over the years it turned into a
hundred thousand dollars but back then
you know the concept of you working and
going to college was was pretty much
right normal but now you come up with 2
500 bucks you can't work and go to
college yeah i paid i paid 100 000 for
my daughter's school i was like where's
she gonna get 100 grand from you know
what i mean it's like she can't do that
um
so 500 went a long way
but it wasn't enough to pay for
everything and my mother
went into they went into debt
my father was resisting the whole time
like man you need to do something else
go to vocational school whatever i was
like look i want to go to college on the
whole thing and she was like look we
only have enough money for one semester
actually she said one year we'll pull
together one year that first 500 helped
the first semester i can help the other
semester but
after that and what happened is i didn't
get a scholarship
that first year and i beg i said just
give me one more semester now you have
to understand too
my brother and sister were lacking
and i asked for everything i literally
was asking everybody to contribute and
it was selfish it was like i can do this
but i need everybody to contribute and
they and it came with a level of
resentment you know i mean it was a
little bit like hey man why should we
put all this into just you you know but
i was like i'm worth it i promise i'll
make it worth it and um they did one
more semester i got a scholarship
and that was let me tell you i that's
with the one moment i found out and knew
that no was negotiable you know like as
long as you just keep going
eventually you're going to get what you
want if you just don't stop
and uh that was a big big moment for me
um getting that scholarship it was it
was incredible but i but i still had a
lot of and this is what's so scary and i
bright about it in the book it's just i
had a lot of entitlement
tons of entitlement because this is
another thing my mother viewed religion
like it was a magic wand you know what i
mean it was
for you you know we
name it and claim it you know in jesus
name i command my bills paid but you do
nothing not a lot of action nothing just
faith to get those bills paid like you
do uh i demand
in jesus name i'm gonna lose 100 pounds
and you die of obesity
and but they wouldn't the lifestyle
would never change
nothing would ever so
you know jesus became a fairy godmother
and i i saw this and i was like
but why don't like and i realized that i
needed to combine
i realized later that i needed to
combine
the talk with the action
but up until that point i was still a
little bit of that same like name it
claim it like hey jesus got me this
and so i was super entitled like i
didn't really want to work you know what
i mean it was like everything
it was out of my control you know what i
mean and i i
basically you know was expecting a
handout
in a lot of ways and my whole attitude
was just a mess man like
to the point where
i wouldn't work you know i
after i got the scholarship i felt like
somebody owed me i had a lot of
resentment to the school
even while i was playing
because i was like yo
about time
you know and it was it's weird how these
little what you would call victories
could actually be
the thing that keep you from true
success you know what i mean yeah it's
interesting i mean
from an outsider looking in it looks
like you get this scholarship it's not
enough so you had the wherewithal to say
i'm gonna walk onto the football team
and turn this into a scholarship and
then turn this into an nfl career that
requires
a lot of action right right and a lot of
self-belief right um but that doesn't
get done unless you're committed because
the odds are stacked against you yep yep
and
i have to say um
even
even with the nfl
um
this is another thing about the nfl
which was really eye-opening you know
you think it's discipline but it's not
it's you know someone's telling you when
to wake up they're telling you when to
eat telling you when to work out telling
you when to practice and tell you when
to go to sleep
um this is why
so many athletes have problems when the
career is over because there's no one to
tell you this stuff anymore it's not
self-discipline it's
the discipline that someone else is
telling you to get everything done but
you're not going to succeed unless you
know how to do this yourself it's just
not going to happen yeah and i i was
left without knowing
any of that i mean your your story of
transcending that into an even you know
bigger career is so the exception and
but you know most guys we think of nfl
players
they're ballers they're making cash
they're living large
most guys have your experience which is
every week they're vying for their job
you're getting traded you're on five or
six teams for maybe two years and and
then you call it a day and it's over and
you're broke yeah most most nfl players
go broke probably within five years
of having that nfl career i mean how are
you ever going to recapture
that you know kind of excitement about
how you're living your life nothing's
going to replace that that's the mistake
see that's what's so crazy
i think
is that can you imagine being 30 years
old and the best thing that was ever
going to happen to you has already
happened
that's nothing but depression right
ahead it's nothing but depression in the
future there's no nothing to look
forward to
and then not only that
you [ __ ] it up
and people and your whole life for 15
years before that was all about getting
to that place so there wasn't a lot of
bandwidth for even thinking about
anything outside of that the fact that
you had this gift as an artist and
something that you were cultivating all
along the way and using as a as a means
of survival yeah um is is unique and
unusual yeah i would go back in the
locker rooms once i got cut and i would
ask the star players if they wanted
their portraits yeah
and i would i would get like five grand
a painting and i would do three
paintings and i would get 15 grand and
that would get me through the off season
you know we were poor man um
but when i told let me the biggest story
i tell
that was my super wake-up call
um
you know my
my best friend to this day is a guy
named ken harvey who used to play with
the redskins that was his backup
and when i moved to la he helped us move
to la
he gave us a loan and he actually i
wouldn't even call it alone it was a
gift he was like just going out there i
i believe in your talent he knew i was a
good artist
and he was like go on out there and make
your way
and i didn't come out to la to act i was
actually trying to get behind the scenes
i saw myself as a creator i mean i was
trying to do that whole um
industrial-like magic thing if i was a
special effects artist i had my
portfolio in at disney at dreamworks
yeah you've shown that you show them the
drug dealer mickey mouse yeah
not that one i could get a cease and
desist letter uh yeah
i definitely didn't show him that one
but it was in the portfolio okay uh but
what was crazy is that um
i thought man this is gonna be my way i
can i can actually draw my way into
hollywood
and then toy story came out and all
hand-drawn animation was over overnight
i remember submitting my artwork for
prince of egypt that was one of the last
hand-drawn animation movies done and
then when toy story hit bam it was over
so but i had this pride and entitlement
still
and i was going through depression
because football was over it didn't end
the way i wanted and you always have
these lofty goals and i was done we were
in this
really you know terrible duplex
um just trying to make ends meet i had
no money i was broke my wife and this
thing my wife the whole time was like
you need a job
and i was like come on i'm you know i'm
a
pro football player it's gonna look
crazy i'm not gonna be just doing
anything right
and so i kept asking my friend for loans
a ken was giving me a loan and what was
happening he would give me he was a gold
bug and he would have all this gold
bouillon some financial advisor had told
him to put money in gold so
you know back then it was
it was that was a big thing a lot of
players were doing got like a stash of
bars yeah they had well it was coins he
would have these rolls of gold coins and
they would be stashed around the house
you know what i mean and that's the new
back now this cryptocurrency is the big
deal but back then it was gold bouyon
and people were always you know they
were advising people to have some of
your money in gold and some of your
money in this he would give me like a
stack of coins and he would say hey man
whatever the price of gold is that day
turn it in and each coin was like 300
bucks so he'd send me like five six
coins and that would get me through the
month but come six eight six seven eight
months down i'm still asking for loans
right
and we're going broke man and i mean
when i say broke we were digging in the
couches for like
just money for milk and it was like and
my wife was like why don't you get a job
man
and i was like yeah but it's gonna work
and because i still had this fantasy of
something's gonna come save me like a mr
eichelberg with a scholarship right or
this and this or again jesus is going to
save us you know you know who i think i
am and i
without me working at all i was using my
mother's technique
right claim it and then one day he said
man
no more loans
when your voice gets all high like that
you know you're doing something wrong
i was like
oh okay okay because you know you
overstepped you know oh my god it was
the first moment of like he just pushed
back
and i hung up and i was like
how the [ __ ] is he
[ __ ] him my whole attitude was like
he's supposed to be a friend and he's
supposed to help me out and i'm saying
he knows i'm out here he knows i'm
struggling what the hell man [ __ ] you
and then this little voice came to me
like hey man
why are you mad at the only person who
helped you in the first place
yeah i went and my family didn't give me
any money nobody else gave me he's the
one who actually was giving me money
i wasn't angry at anybody else who told
me no
i was only angry at the person who
actually hooked me up right which is
related to resenting western michigan
for giving you a scholarship you see
what's that weird thing the same thing
imagine if you if you just gave ten
dollars to some person every day and all
of a sudden you go that's it there we go
where's my where's my 10 bucks
that's where i was at
and i was like i didn't i didn't deserve
that i never earned it it was something
that was a gift and he was like no more
and it hit me man i said i'm wrong man
but remember remember my wife was
telling me this the whole time but
because i was a man
and because i viewed myself as more
valuable than she was
all her advice was
secondary it was as if my kids were
telling me something yeah and because i
came at it as this attitude of what
masculinity is you you're supposed to
already know
so any
you know what your wife is saying is bad
man
she was telling the truth the whole time
but it's so crazy i would listen when
ken said it
it hit me
another man told me i was like oh damn
and so the next day
i got up like 4 30 in the morning went
to this place called labor ready
it's i mean i'll never forget what in
north hollywood
uh five in the morning i show up with
but drug addicts
uh
halfway house guys you know straight out
of prison
trying to make it whole thing homeless
and i show up and they what they do at
labor ready is give you a job for the
day and you get paid at the end of the
day and they sent me to this place
called white cap
um and it was somewhere i i forget i
think it was somewhere in um
in the valley right
some valley somewhere
and i would go in there and hand me a
broom
now let me tell you something man i
thought i was gonna pass out
i said
if i start like man i was in the nfl
now i got this broom in my hand in a
factory and i'm like oh oh i think i
thought i was just going to fall to the
ground
all of a sudden i took that thing and
man our tears just welling up like
this might be my life
this might be
where i'm at how did i fall so low how
did i get from the nfl and all the
promise of the artwork and then and then
and the scholarship and then i'm
sweeping the damn floor
in a factory
but this is the craziness about it it
was so wow
i started
and all sweeping
a sudden
i felt
an energy
and and i mean people were like man hey
man you look a little familiar man you
don't know me you know i put my hat down
a little
further and i kept sweeping but i got
new energy because i was actually for
the first time
doing something about my situation
whereas before i was just sitting wait
yeah and i was like oh my god
and so i was like let me get in the
corners and let me let me do this job
because
another thing is the resisting work is
worth it's the hard part
but embracing work the day goes by like
that
and well you know i mean yeah yeah yeah
no i got it i mean it's it's uh it's
interesting that you were able to like
do that math quickly like generally it
takes a lot longer before you
kind of are lured into a place of
surrender to it but that acceptance like
i'm gonna be a worker among workers is
an act of humbling yourself
but that's the place where you can begin
to grow i mean this is like a big you
know you're sober now like you
understand like
that that peace that acceptance and that
that humility is so important to growth
right getting over your own
you know self-aggrandizement and idea of
who you think you should be and how
people are supposed to interact with you
is a really
beautiful thing right and i and as
you're telling that story i'm thinking
about your dad polishing his shoes like
you have so little agency it's like the
surrender the the serenity prayer right
like
like there are so few things that you
have control over but you know what i
have control over i have control over
how i conduct myself yes with this job
today and i can do it with a sense of
gratitude and pride and that's going to
make it worth it oh man there's a there
is a
poem
that i heard that i just love it says um
and i can't pronounce the name of the
guy who wrote it it's i i'll massacre it
but it it goes it says i slept and
dreamt of joy
i awoke
and realized
life was service
i worked
and behold service was joy
whoa
that's it it's beautiful it's so
beautiful and i went
that's what was happening
and i did that eight hours
i went back got my check it was like 64
they took out the taxes i had 48 dollars
i put 20 in the gas tank
i gave 20 to my wife for groceries and i
had eight dollars in my hand
and i said i will never be broke again
because you know you say it takes a
while
but it happened it kind of cracked that
egg when i walked in there
the fact that i actually got in the car
that morning and went in was
you it's like that's the egg crack
the the sweeping was when it started to
sizzle you know what i mean but i had
because i was spit months not moving
but that
i mean i broke through
that
thing because i thought everyone was
gonna look at me and everyone's gonna
judge me and nobody cares no because
they're thinking about themselves
exactly no one is thinking about you you
know what i mean no one even knew me and
that was this this obstacle this huge
like
wall that i felt like i had to climb
and i realized nobody gives a bam about
where i'm at so how long did you do that
for oh man probably a a week
a week and then well i went and applied
for another because once i broke that i
went and applied at another place called
western staff services
and then i got a job
being a i was filing all the papers that
fell over in the northridge earthquake
at the veterans administration i was
like this is better than sweeping right
and so but i was i was a filer and so i
did that for a year
but i didn't have to do the the man the
hard labor stuff but let me tell you
something man
as i started to go and i started to i
said okay we're here
this is my life now
and i started to grow i started to grow
now mind you there was still a lot of
things i didn't get right
but i started to understand the
entitlement piece
it was like you are not owed anything
and i started to say you have to work
for this
you know this is not a you gotta
understand that that religious mindset
was actually like a lottery mentality
you know i mean we just keep playing god
we keep rolling on god it's gonna hit
for us one day you know what i mean and
you're left with nothing but i realize i
can do something like you said it was
the serenity prayer the things that i
can control
control it you know what i mean and
but for a long long time i felt i
couldn't even control what happened to
me like
myself i couldn't like if the wind went
right i was going right
and the wind went that way i was
succumbed to that and i realized i could
walk straight i could really really
handle my own business
my in myself and
and then i started doing security for
the movie sets
and let me tell you something i love
that gig
it's why when i look back
the first movie i ever did a security
board was a movie called man on the moon
with jim carrey
danny devito
milos foreman was the director and i was
standing and i'm never forgetting my
cast security shirt and i would iron my
shirts and get batteries in my
flashlight
and i would work out and make sure that
i looked great and
and i was like i'm in the movie business
right i'm in the movie business you know
what i mean it was so
and i was like i'm on a set i'm on this
whole thing and that was the
the really wonderful thing and i was
happy man like i'll tell you this if
if i'll never forget being like this is
my life now
i got settled to this is what it's going
to be
and i had no idea
what was in store for me so you weren't
casting your your gaze on some goal and
like working in your free time to move
forward on that
we're just like this is where i'm at and
this is what it's going to be but let me
tell you i was working on my free time
because what i would do is while i was
standing there like doing that stuff i
would write scripts
write down ideas i would go to the
library because i couldn't afford to buy
the books i would buy books on hollywood
and when no one was around because
sometimes they would have me watching
areas that they didn't want mess with so
there was nobody so i would just read
the books all day and just stand there
and read the books yeah and just learn
about the business and learn about all
this stuff and but was it still about
being an artist in the business or was
the idea of being an actor starting to
creep in artists right artists never an
actor but you have that that experience
on set for training day right right
which is pretty cool but listen
this is even freakier um i was security
on a movie called end of days arnold
schwarzenegger
jeff dawn who is arnold's makeup artist
was walking on the set and he was he
came up to me and i was a security guard
and i was like okay extras go this way
you know crew is over here he looked at
me he said hey man
why you ever act and i went oh no sir
that's not me he was like dude
he said you got a great look man you
need i'm serious you really need to try
it
he said i'm a makeup artist i do makeup
and i'm arnold's guy
i'm here to tell you you got a great
look i thought he was hitting on me
so
i was like uh thank you sir
extras are this way and crew is that way
thank you very much
flash forward one year later
i'm on i'm
hired actor
on the movie the sixth day with
schwarzenegger i go into the makeup
trailer there's jeff dawn
and he says
you wait a minute you look familiar i
said
you told me a year ago
that i should be acting and here i am he
said holy [ __ ] like
i said i'm making people rich here
i see he said you you're kidding
that's like you can't even make this up
no that's crazy you can't and you had
the the security gig that came full
circle too right right
listen man
when i look at
you know i remember just every
opportunity it's kind of like
you realize you if you wrote this stuff
it's it would be contrived you know what
i mean it's
truth is stranger than fiction in every
way
and uh
my thing is you know from being a
security guy
and acting it was because we were broke
and a friend of mine
because i was bouncing i i had like
three two or three jobs i would do the
security gig they all bounce and a
friend of mine was like hey man there's
this audition for this one show you
should try it
and now i went home and i said you know
so many i asked my wife so many people
telling me i should try this acting
thing
she said why not yeah just go
and i went and i got it first thing i
ever auditioned for the battle down
thing battle dog which was american
gladiators on steroids okay and this is
where all the football stuff everything
played out
and
my first time as an actor and
now i got the gig and i'm like i don't
know anything about what acting is right
so i did hear what you asked for let me
tell you what i did i did what i did
when the kids would talk about star wars
and i would go home and start drawing it
out and think about what it is even
though i hadn't seen the movie what i
did was create a character that i said
okay i don't know what i don't know how
to act but i know what i want to see
so what i'm going to do is be
what i want to see
how would i like to be seen like if i
was watching
what would i do
and i became the breakout character i
became this guy named t-money who was
this bad guy from the hood and the whole
thing and i was just ambitious and mean
and i would never let the contestant see
me because it was a game show where we
fought they put me in a cage shut the
end zone fire and rotate the cage and i
would just wrestle three contestants in
a row and it was bloody i mean we would
leave bleeding every show this is metal
skin on metal
it was pre-mma so there was no ultimate
fighting no one knew anything about that
but man it if you look at the clips it
was one of the most brutal
the log line for the show
was real competition real pain mm-hmm
and that's all you need to know
that's it yeah right and we
man we blasted people but
what was happening is i was learning how
it was like grand theater
it was a lesson it was a whole thing
like i was and let me tell you i can't
tell you the nerves ever
they would put me behind a wall and
every time the wall opened up and the
warrior we would come out and every time
i felt like throwing up every time
because i i don't know what i'm doing
and i wanted to run out of there but i
was like what am i going to run to
what am i going to run to
i'm going to be back to security
back to sweeping floors
i said hell no
and i had to go i had to push it was the
thing where you go you've walked halfway
across the country what are you gonna do
turn around yeah yeah i mean like you
gotta keep walking now yeah that
impostor syndrome i mean because you
don't have you still have never really
done any kind of formal training right
and you have that story about uh uh of
working on the expendables where you
have that same experience where you have
to kind of reckon with yourself like how
am i gonna show up for this yeah
let me tell you about that what was wild
is because the sense of entitlement
creeped back up
i had already done a few movies done
some things i ended up in the
expendables
and
i felt i wasn't getting used enough like
i'm thinking i'm excited about being an
action star and i'm sitting in my hotel
room
and all of a sudden sly and everybody
they're going on the set and doing it
everyone else has done like 30 action
movies right and i haven't even been a
leading man for like their whole adult
lives
how this is how
insidious
the attitude of entitlement can be
it doesn't matter it sneaks right in
someone gives you a little bit all of a
sudden you're like why didn't i get the
whole thing
it's it's so
perva it's so pervasive but i was
sitting in my hotel room
and uh i was so mad and
i would go on and i was i was like man
instead of just being grateful
i said you
[Music]
the same voice that told me
about ken and like why are you mad at
him
it was like hey man
you got this opportunity of a lifetime
what the [ __ ] are you doing like
man go in there and do your best every
time who cares
and so what i did
i said i hit me i said man you're right
like
all that alone time which which i'm very
thankful for
really help with the introspection
because what happens is if you got too
many people around too many crew
they can really talk you out of your
dream they can really mess you up you're
like yeah you know what you should be
why why are you not stop you know and
and you get those wrong validating
opinions
and you're off
and you and that crew will take you
right out and i was alone
and i went to work the next day and i
was thankful i said man just
i don't care what i'm feeling i said i'm
gonna get everything i got
and i walked in and said hello to
everybody and i was like what's the
lines and i started to improv and do and
sly was like man
hey man i like you man i'm gonna put you
in over this day
you're gonna save my life in this movie
that's what he told me
he said i'm and i totally changed what
happened in that movie that experience
changed
because of my attitude change right so
he ends up rewriting the ending to make
you the hero it was dude and i couldn't
believe it and i realized that was so
like that was a another lesson same
lesson like when i got my scholarship
it was that lesson that like wait a
minute man
you know this you can change
this thing you can your attitude
can never ever waver you have to have
you can't let entitlement creep in and
steal what what's yours
yeah gratitude being the antidote to
entitlement exactly so how does i mean
you've spoken a lot about gratitude how
you know you're the most grateful person
but gratitude is a practice it didn't
come to you easily early so how do you
make sure that you're on top of your
gratitude well you know i i basically
you know you look at your results
you look at where you are you look at
what's happening you know what i mean
and
one thing is um i always can this is one
thing even like writing a book
journaling
uh i would used to write my top 10 goals
down
every day and i did that for probably 15
years so i have you know the franklin
planner remember those yeah uh i have
tons of those those stacked up
and what helps me with gratitude i go
back
to
2001 my franklin planner and look at
those top 10 goals
and i did them all like
way exceeded them like and then i go
back to 2005 and i go i did all that
and i go into 2008 i did all that
and it's so
it fills me with the gratitude that i'm
supposed to have because you know where
you were
and what was so amazing at that time
like if i could only make a million
dollars a year
you know what i mean and you go wow
wow
i've gone way better you're like
holy god right it's it's a it's a weird
thing like i'm really interested in this
so
you know in my own case like it's wild
that i'm sitting across from you and
that i get to do this thing and it's not
anything that ever found its way into my
version of the franklin planner so it's
this
tension between yes you want to set
goals for yourself and you want to work
hard and show up and be diligent but
also you have to make space for the
miracle because you can't imagine
what your life could possibly be right
like you have to you have to hold that
that that
tension with the goals that you're
seeking a little bit loosely so you can
make space for
stuff that you can't even predict for
yourself and for me
it always goes back to the inside job
like how much am i working on myself
where are my blind spots where are the
things that you know i could be more
grateful um or you know work on some
other area and it seems completely
disconnected from whatever goal i'm
seeking in the external world but all i
know is that when i'm when i'm doing
that when i'm engaged in that process
that's where i'm sort of taking that
insurance policy out on greater
possibility that i can't quite fathom
exactly
you know and i
had to find these challenges like
there's a there's a thing because you
you you get complacent
and it's the comfort zone
and there was a time as an actor you're
like you're gonna get hired
it's all good and you're gonna be on a
sitcom or some sort of show you'll be
the fourth lead and you'll be like and
you can just live that life like you
know you'll be that guy on the csi or
whatever brooklyn nine-nine yeah
or another version of that yeah so you
can just do but this is the thing
i was like
there's more
and i i felt too comfortable
and it made me weird because i was going
i don't like complacency uh because i'm
i'm a little i started to study it and
start to look at it and it was like man
you're getting a little
like
it's almost like getting chubby
you know what i mean where you're like
i'm just eating the same things
i'm not really i said i need a challenge
i need something that's going to excite
me so i started i forced myself into
hosting
forced by like you got to understand
240-pound
muscular
big guy was not the first guy you would
think of as a television yeah but you
got the charm and the charisma but the
smile and the teeth and the whole thing
but now yeah uh at the time
people they were like does he
i know him from everybody's chris
i know him from
you know this kind of thing but but and
so i remember uh going in and doing an
audition for who wants to be a
millionaire the daily version of that
and let me tell you i could tell you
that it was actually a failure okay
that
was not a good look um because here i
was on a game show the daily version of
a show that'd been on tv for years and
i'm this character who talked way too
loud for the daytime audience hey how
you guys doing yeah yeah so i over
compensated and it was a little much for
that audience because you know the
people were like well i'm drinking my
tea and he's screaming at me stop
screaming all the notes were like stop
screaming you know um and here i was and
i would do this daily thing i did
360 episodes
in a year of
who wants to be a millionaire
while i was doing brooklyn nine-nine
so i would fly to the east coast
do the show and then do like we would do
almost seven episodes in a day like
all day i was exhausted then fly back
and go right to brooklyn nine-nine
but i said i have to get this
like it was hook or cook i said i'm
going to learn this and they gave me an
opportunity to do it and let me tell you
it didn't go well because they fired me
the first year i mean when the year was
over they were like
we're gonna they went with chris
harrison i had to understand i was like
oh man it just didn't work out so there
i was i said i gave i put my heart i had
actors are like why are you doing this
they would come up to me and they will
say terry like man you could be doing
this acting why don't you do some more
movies i want you to i said but because
what i saw was the future i saw
i got tired of waiting to be picked
and i said if i learned the skill
that i don't have to be i could shoot i
can choose you know there's not a lot of
people like when you look at big stupid
stars or people they just charm doesn't
mean you can host it doesn't mean you
can do all that stuff yeah it's a whole
nother thing i said i have to learn this
and man
what was so wild and to do to this day
this is when you this is to your point
about leaving room
i'm hosting the number one talent show
in the world yeah with fourth year
and i look at this like this was never
on the list
i didn't know it would go this far i was
just trying to secure a future
hopefully do some things
and you know that would allow me to
pivot in different ways but never did i
see this yeah it's crazy it's crazy it's
the biggest show in the world and i
gotta tell you
i i think you know i will admit to being
somewhat dismissive of the whole host
thing like ah come on that's not like
real
acting that's not you know they're
reading off the prompter and the whole
thing but i just had to
host an all-day conference in miami i do
a fair amount of speaking i was like how
hard could it be you know and i go there
and i'm like holy [ __ ] like i'm
responsible for holding the energy for
this group of you know this huge
auditorium of people for like an
eight-hour stretch like i better get my
[ __ ] together
ended up like rehearsing for eight hours
wrote a 35-page script
and
and you know had to go out in between
each speaker and come up with jokes on
the fly
and i ended up leaving that experience a
with just a huge amount of respect for
how difficult that job is and how
specific that skill set is and how
different it is from
typical public speaking and also any
other kind of like performance oriented
thing that i'd ever done
but also
it's completely thrilling like it's so
gratifying like because you you are like
you have to have these people in your
hands right you know and if when you're
in your kind of flow and you know that
you're firing on all cylinders it's a
pretty cool thing let me tell you you
know what i like to call it they give me
the keys to nbc
yeah i get the keys i mean it's the best
you have it's the biggest show in the
world wait and it goes
and you have nbc
in your hand
there's only you
and everyone's looking at you and it's
like those doors open you walk out
and you are representing everything
you're representing 30 rock you're
representing simon cowell you represent
every act you represent to show me it's
been on for 17 years
and you have it in your hands
and it's like
oh and it reminded me of the nfl
you know what i mean it was that
thrilling like the ball could go
anywhere poop oh and it's live by the
way
live so anything can happen right you
know i'll never forget the prompter goes
out happens
you still have to keep the show going
and you have to explain the rules and
others because it's rules there's things
that people want to try to win money you
can't miss it you misinterpret it people
get sued it's crazy it's that pressure
and the property goes out and you still
have to know what you're talking about
and when and it's like oh my god and
dude i'll go home i'm exhausted but
every fiber of my being is exhausted and
i'm happy like i just played in the
super bowl yeah you know what i mean
yeah because you're the glue i mean the
the the panelists have to weigh in on
the acts but they're not responsible for
keeping the show moving not at all yeah
no they i go to them for an answer i
give them a question and but then i i'm
responsible for bringing an act out
introducing these guys explaining the
rules to the public and i am and it's so
thrilling i can't like you said
dude and then you think it's full
the place is full of you know
probably
what 6 thousand people in adobe
and then you turn around and say no
that's it's really a hundred million
people watch
that kind of thing
holy yeah
we had uh o's pearlman in here the other
day do you remember him the mentalist
yes
i'm sorry
um
who ended up i think he ended up third
maybe five years ago or something like
that do you remember that guy no he he
did that he's the mentalist yes the
mentalist yes
i remember him
i know it's unbelievable that the
quality of talent and all that all the
stuff that you get to see but i'm going
to tell you this and
let me tell you every act that comes
through reminds me of me
it reminds me of
being in flint michigan
dreaming of being
so somehow involved in entertainment you
know no matter what it is
and everybody had huge huge obstacles to
get to that point huge
and a lot of people say well you know
yeah who hates the sob story and whole
thing but there's not an entertainer
that doesn't
because it's all rejection yeah all of
it you just have to find ways to deal
with your rejection and um
so i look at these acts and i'm their
bodyguard i'm that protector i'm the
person
that
that gives them what they need on the
way out and then i'm the person that
counsels them
on when they come back out from the
audience you know what i mean and it's
like if it doesn't go well i let them
know that this is just the beginning
and if it goes great i let them know you
got to come back next week with more you
know it's just it's it's and it reminds
me of me and and also
i try to the people that are successful
i really really try to pull something
that they and learn something from them
yeah you know i mean and it's just a
beautiful
relationship i learned a lot doing that
show man because you meet so many
different people and
it's one of the highlights of my life
but
it really really was one of those things
that had to
i had to get out of my comfort zone i
had to find something new and and i'll
be honest with you i don't know what's
next i i've been designing furniture
right um
and my wife is like why are you doing
this i'm like i don't know i just
you gotta feel the hardest though right
are you painting still i'm painting i'm
drawing i'm sketching
still designing i'm in the fourth
iteration of my my uh collection with
bernhardt
but there's something else coming like i
right now i've been challenging myself
to do you know more dramatic things um
you know i did a scent on um a show
called tales of the walking dead which
is not funny at all um
i love that challenge i see myself doing
but this is another thing man
writing these books
and being so vulnerable and
putting my story out there
it's like moving from fiction to
non-fiction
is what i like to say it's it's
literally
the next step what i feel in my career
is it's beyond being an actor
but being a person
of interest you know where
let's talk about things together being
you know because this is another thing
like being a host
it's almost like
being able to have conversations with
people and learn from people and tell
your story
is the only way we're gonna get by
problems this is why you and i are
sitting here right now
it's because this is nuance
and what we are witnessing right now is
the death of nuance
no one is talking everyone is screaming
at each other just look at any daytime
talk show it's all yelling at each other
and
at the end of the day it's like you know
we show we showed you bow you know might
drop
and we'll see you tomorrow and i'm going
it gets the hits it charges the dopamine
but ultimately
everybody as a human being has that deep
desire for
connection and for
nuance and i think that's a big reason
why
you know podcasts have have grown in
popularity people would people would
tell me all the time like you got to
make these things 30 minutes like who's
going to listen to you guys banter on
forever but
you know it's been quite the opposite
because i think people are starving for
it honestly it is it is you know our
version of the campfire and we need that
campfire if we want to solve our
problems and
the solution to our problems lies in
appreciation of nuance and you can only
get to the nuance when you take the time
to sit down and calmly you know talk
through stuff that i think is important
[Music]
[Music]
you know and we haven't even gotten to
like the main thing that i want to talk
to you about which is
like
d-day
yeah you know you being this really
successful person who on you know from
an exterior view had it all going on
inside you're a very different person
ultimately you have this this bottom
this reckoning
that becomes a catalyst for all the
growth and the expansion
that you're able to kind of exude and
speak to now look you know
this is so crazy and
and it hit me so hard you know
that
there i was
i was
extremely successful
i mean living a life living a dream like
i said look going through my franklin
planner and realizing i hit every last
one of my goals
and i was miserable
and my family was miserable
and no one liked me
and i said
that that can't be it there has to be
another level of success and
and what i discovered is that
you know i wasn't
real um i had created an image
i had created terry crews
you know
with a restricted you know tm trademark
you know i mean it was like
um
it wasn't real
and but everybody loved it everybody
loved it it was so good it was so pure
and amazing everybody loves terry crews
on
but my wife knew
i knew
because this the problem is i i never
told my wife about my pornography
addiction
and
back in 2010 we had a day called d-day
and
it was wild because that's the day i
confess
to
basically going to a a massage parlor
getting a hand job
and cheating on my wife 10 years earlier
which was back in 2000
and um but i vow when that happened i
mean it was probably the darkest day of
my life because
that's where my addiction had brought me
mm-hmm and i was just like man i never
thought
again what it's just like those good
goals that happen you're like i never
thought i'd be here
but those bad habits brought me to i
never thought
i would be here
and it was the hardest i just bowed i
would never tell anybody i vowed that's
my secret to take to the grave i'll
never say it yeah the big fear being if
you actually told your wife who you were
that that she she would leave and and
this is the let me tell you the biggest
trick about that and the biggest lie
and the thing is is that
what we're really searching for is
intimacy as men
i don't i don't again i'm not going to
speak for women but i know for me
intimacy is what i need
but the problem is if you never tell who
you really are
you can never find true intimacy
and this is where you could be as a guy
going from sexual
experience just sex sex sex sex and
never finding anything that's meaningful
because you're not revealing who you are
you know what i mean and it's like i had
this image that my wife had married
and what she thought was her life but it
was really not
and she
but she was always suspicious so she
would always ask me and i remember
because of my guilt i would start an
argument
um just to get out of contractions
right
lack of trust and that kind of running
and oh my god look at that and i'm out
of here um
and i and i there was a wall and every
time i used pornography
it created a wall between us now this is
the thing
and you know
it's different if two couples are into
it and they want to do that the whole
thing well then there's your your
transparency right there
but
to be hiding something
is a whole other matter and the way i
like to to phrase it sometimes because
guys a lot of times don't understand
they feel like man you know i remember
guys so you know we enjoy looking at
women you know what can it be what kind
of problem but the thing i like to say
is imagine if
if your wife was taking money from
another guy and didn't tell you
what
immediately guys go what are you talking
about
just imagine if some guy was giving your
wife money
there's a thousand dollars and two
thousand dollars
and you find out
for three years
she's been taking money from another guy
we didn't have sex we didn't do anything
but you know
you know i'm a woman i need money
and
guys would be like hell no
no not if you're gonna be if you
consider yourself my wife or you no
we're not gonna do that in fact that's
unacceptable in fact what are you doing
and
the flip side
is exactly how your wife feels
it's like why are you getting that from
someone else
i was supposed to be that
that's released was my wife's attitude
and
just to help people kind of frame the
picture
i had had this thing where i was more
valuable
than the women in my life simply because
i was a man first of all sports culture
told me that
black culture told me that
uh male culture told me that everything
in my life said
it's your way or the highway hey man i
didn't love my family i owned my family
and you're supposed to do what i say i
wasn't really listening to you
it was blah blah blah
but a true equal can come to you and you
have to respect what they say a true
equal can challenge you
on your beliefs and on your moves and
say
i got a problem with that terry but i
wouldn't even allow that because you're
not an equal to me so what was the
reckoning how did that change
well first of all she left
when when i told her
because this was the thing
d-day
went like this
what is it i don't know about you terry
crews that's what she asked me
because and i was on the phone with her
for like two hours just like
but she's like there's something i'm
you're something you're doing i don't
know it was again you see that that
woman getting some money you're like
where'd you get that
sometimes you know two and two equals
four it's not adding up something's up
and and i just
i was tired i was tired of lying i was
tired of being done i was i was actually
done with the relationship
i was done with the marriage it was one
of them things like
why why even keep putting up with this
because first of all
hollywood didn't care if i lose my
family
i'd get more movies they'd be like hey
man good you got no wife to come home
too you can do three more projects and
she's the only one challenging you only
one
only one because
hollywood doesn't care porn shoot
no big deal
it's like in fact we'll get you some
girls
and i literally
was done with my marriage because i was
feeling like
again back to entitlement
but also not appreciating not
no gratitude for what she's done
but i had moved into this i'm terry
crews though
because that's the image
and i got i told her
and she just i can't like to me i was
like what happened ten years ago and to
be honest it was a little bit like where
are you gonna go like
i'm terri you know i got all this i'm
doing good oh man the attitude was
horrendous it was horrendous
and uh and she was just like i can't
believe
like to her it happened the same day
but to me i'm like i was 10 years
earlier
she said i'm done she said don't come
home
don't and i'll say okay i won't
fine i said go
i said you know i can just go find
another woman like that so
you know whatever you want to do you can
do and she was like i hung up and my
marriage was over
and then that same damn voice
that little voice the one that talked to
me
way back in the day about ken harvey the
little voice that was talking to me all
this time
they said man
what if it's not her
what if it's you
no i can't beat me can't be me look
first of all i'm doing everything i'm
supposed to do i'm successful i'm
successful i have done this business and
the fact that look at where i came from
i'm a black man i was poor i made it all
the way up here i did all these things i
got a high sex drive you know i mean so
you know what i mean i got i got a
little more testosterone and an average
man i mean i had
you know i had
totally
made that thing up
and i was all in the image and
all of a sudden it said
but
it's you though
and the question i used to frame i would
frame the question about all this stuff
i would ask my you know like i would
think about my wife and i'd be like why
didn't she believe me
and in an instant that question changed
to why am i lying
same context but one was blaming her
and the other one was like
this is me
i'm lying
i've been lying the whole time
you did lie
like
you could you could say you weren't but
you were lying the whole time
and then i knew i said man i'm in
trouble like i started to have a crisis
and when i say that
it was like i didn't care about
hollywood anymore
i didn't care about like at first it's
like i'll just keep moving and i just do
more movies but you're like but i don't
care about doing movies
it was a crisis when i say a crisis it
was like i don't care about anything
i'm done like i'm a farce
yeah it feels like porn opened up the
door but what it really was was like an
existential reckoning with the fact that
you've been living
some version of a double life for a very
long time until it just became so
unsustainable and exhausting that you
had if you had to confront it first of
all that's the way all these things work
all these vices
you know some people may make so much
money they can gamble until they can't
until they're taking the house
some they drink all day until
you get
your liver can't take anymore yeah it
works until it's not working anymore
until it's not working yeah that's what
my friend steven tyler said says all
addictions work until they stop working
yeah uh-oh
and then they don't work for a while
until they reach your pain tolerance and
you're probably a guy who can deal with
a lot of pain right so as the elevator
is going down
the excuses start to stack up until it
just becomes so unmanageable that you
have to like throw your hands up and
give up
you know the thing about
excuses thing man and i learned it's
funny because excuses are valid for a
minute
but then it's like an expired credit
card man you're running around and you
keep trying to plunk that thing down
and you get declined you know what i
mean it's kind of like
every excuse does not work and
listen when i got declined by my wife i
put the credit card down like hey here
you go it's like no that's expired man
but responsibility gives you a whole new
credit limit
like the minute you start taking
responsibility
you start to build that credit back up
you start doing all this stuff so i went
and i went to counseling and now this is
another thing is in
black culture where i grew up you did
not get therapy uh it was seen as you
can't cure crazy if you're crazy you
can't cure it you know every family had
an uncle that they would lock in the
basement or
somebody upstairs who just wasn't all
together and you just go to church and
pray that's it you pray about it and you
just you got to deem it
that was what it would say
so-and-so's got to demon
and that was it like
you but there was no cure
and and if you get that mumble jumbo and
you all of a sudden you're going to be
more confused
and how i learned this is that what was
so crazy is my father went to a
psychologist to deal with his alcoholism
and the psychologist killed himself
i was a teenager and i was like that's
it wow that you're right he jumped off a
bridge and i went
yeah they're all crazy and i said and so
i had this
and i was not this thing like i'm not
gonna get near that and but that was the
moment when i said
i went to my i called my friend in the
middle of d-day
and he said man
he said i don't i can't tell you you're
going to get your wife back
but you need to get better for you
now it was a strange concept
i got to explain this because everything
i did
was to get something
like every bit of work every bit i was
doing good so that i can get money or
working hard so i can get this working
but there was never a realization of
doing of getting
of just doing something for
your own sake just being good to be good
just to be better because that's again
that's internal that's something
it was always external rewards but
he said you need to get better for you
and i was like what
you know i would do whatever to get sex
or do whatever to get money but even the
working out even all of that was so you
could front or show up and look a
certain way yes and it was again you
worked out so you could show people
i'm not to be messed with you know that
kind of thing or if that was back when i
was young or and then you show out the
soul just show
how great you are you know what i mean
but
but just to do it
for me
anyway
i knew i went to i went to
rehab yeah first day in rehab i was like
oh i got dude i'm in the wrong place
this is not where did you go did you go
to like meadows or some place no i went
to a place called psychological
counseling services in phoenix
phoenix arizona
uh and i'm sitting in that room with
about 10 other people
and they're all talking their issues and
i'm going and the whole thing it was a
little bit like this was the same thing
like going to labor ready
where i was like everybody's going to
care
everybody but everybody had their own
damn issues that they had to deal with
and so and i was thinking everybody's
gonna know it's me and everybody but i
said damn it
i gotta go and listen and i did not go
to get my wife back my whole thing i i
really
knew my marriage was over
i just said well i'm just gonna have to
try to
get myself together and
when i did
and after the first day i was like this
is not me and then all of a sudden they
were like hey man was your dad alcoholic
i was like yeah
and so was your mom very religious i was
like oh how'd you know that
wait and they started reading my mail
like it was all these things
that started to come down and i was like
oh my god
that is me this is me
and
it just dude it changed
everything like i went on this journey
and i still i'm still on it um for 12
straight years
i i probably like every time i'm in the
gym i have an audio book going about
cognitive therapy about thinking about
thinking
about re-examining all the things you
know
um
there's one book that i love it's like
um
you are not so smart it's a book that
totally revamps the way you think things
are and they're not
and then there's another book that
followed it called you are now less dumb
so i started to think
my way my way through life instead of
because remember now
women this is one way that i think women
can tend to be
a lot smarter than guys because they
they don't push their way through things
they have to think their way through
life you know what i mean so
they know that they're it's a lot more
intuitive
uh whereas
with
amen
within male culture
if you got the biggest bench press you
run the business
you you don't know anything about
inventory or anything about it but if
you're the strongest guy they everybody
treats you like that's what if you're
super tall you're a basketball player
you are the king of the world
right and that's the way those the
operations that's the way we operate
and i had to start thinking for the
first time for real
about who i want to be where i'm at
and what was happening in that whole
course
i had to raise my life like totally dump
truck it man like
i started all over from the beginning
and um
i went on a 90-day sex fast yeah
like and
i'll never forget because we went 75
days the first year and we you know and
my wife was willing to you know come
back in and i would think she's like
well we don't have she said i'll let you
back in and the whole thing and and
we'll be good but
the next year they always got me i said
we went to 75 i said we got to do it
again
so the next year i went on another
fast and i made it the whole 90 days
because i said it was so important to me
because this was the thing man
remember
i had let my body and my my these things
overcome what i wanted to do so if i
wanted sex i would get it if i wanted to
eat i would do it if i didn't eat it
because i was like i have no control
but i said i said i have to control
these things like
and if that means
fasting these things and so i actually
haven't ate breakfast for 12 years
i've been intermittent fasting right
since we're gonna get into that but like
yeah that practice of of i mean it's
really
it's powerful and empowering
because it puts you into contact with
the truth of the behavior like you it's
not until you you stop doing it that you
realize
that you you start to understand the
reasons why you were doing it like that
you were doing it to check out
emotionally or to act out or to serve
some kind of you know internal [ __ ] up
need that you have because when you're
in the process of doing it it's so
normalized right like i know i went to
treatment and back in 98
and and it was suggested to me that i
take a year celibate after leaving
treatment
because my relationship with the
opposite sex was so convoluted with my
alcoholism yeah and i couldn't i it was
because i was so insecure around the
opposite sex or i would you know i would
rely all everything was like a mess and
the only way to get clear was to put
that distance between those two things
for an extended period of time
and it was so empowering and i i could i
i really because then it's just you and
you yeah and you got to deal with that
[ __ ]
right and there's no escape from it and
i learned a ton and then when the year
ended i met my wife and that was that
amen you know well you know
that's how i felt i felt like i met my
wife
after that
that was so crazy we we've been married
for 20 years
at that point
and going through that i felt like i met
my wife
which is nuts that's funny you would say
that because
you know you know there was a time in
our lives man when we were 12
and you have a crush on a girl or
whatever and you pull a flower out
you ain't thinking about sex
i didn't even know what it was i just
was like all i could think about is like
i appreciate this girl
i appreciate who she is just for she's
beautiful because she's just her
it was beyond what her body looked like
and then it was just like i there's a
feeling of care like i care for you
i want to see you win
i want to see you succeed
and it had nothing to do with sex
and that's exactly what i felt for my
wife at those nine with those 90 days it
became our conversation started to talk
about
it it wasn't about what was going to
happen at the end of the combo you know
what i mean because it's funny how over
the years with porn and different things
it was like all right well you know what
that means we had a good convo now you
got to do something for me
it was the tit-for-tat yeah
and
[Music]
but there's no when you have a real
conversation
with no expectations of all this getting
but it was all giving
dude it was a whole nother level
and it allowed
our relationship to be rebuilt
and beyond that
you start to reckon with your anger
and with all of these other you know we
started this conversation talking about
unhealthy masculinity it really helped
you unpack all these other aspects of
your life and
you know traumas that you experienced as
a young person to to you know get whole
with all of that i mean that's really
the broader message than just
again it's like the porn that brings you
in the door yeah but ultimately the gift
was so much more expansive again i the
phrase i use is cracking that egg you
can't it's starts to spill
or you you hit that first domino
you know and the dominoes just keep
going you know it was like oh my god
like
because i get the road getting narrower
yeah yeah
yeah and i i mean
i was very violent man i mean there's a
long list of people
who
jerry crews has knocked out okay
um which was crazy it i start the book
out talking about a time in pasadena we
were headed to the
the longest yard wrap party and this guy
i felt disrespected my wife while we
were waiting for a car
and man i put him on his head on the
concrete dude like
it was overkill
you know
in every sense of the word
you know what i mean it was like whoa
and uh the police came
and it's a crowded you know a bunch of
people it was christmas people were
christmas shopping so it was packed in
downtown pasadena
and man
um thank god thank god this man this
this older white man came out of the
crowd and said i saw this whole thing
and they were just waiting for their car
and they were bothered by this gentleman
so but the police came with their hands
on their guns ready to arrest somebody
and my wife was shook
she was like terry
we went home after all that and she said
you have to promise me you'll never do
that again you have to promise you she
said i'll be okay
but you have to promise me and i was
like what are you talking about i said
i'm a man like this is what men do
this i said first of all i can't make
that kind of promise
because when somebody needs their ass
whoop i'm i'm going to be there to
deliver it
because i had no problem with that you
know i mean i mean
but dude she was like terry
there's a
imagi this is
like at it's at the minimum we could get
sued
and lose everything
and at the maximum the police could
choose yeah yeah exactly like it's a
couple things i mean first of all this
is how the book opens so you open with a
pal
um and
short of the white guy telling the white
cops that
they should be going after the other
black eye not you the black eye i mean
that's a whole conversation right there
right yes um but also it's impossible to
read the first few pages of your book
and not think about what the whole will
smith thing i mean the parallel between
that episode and what the world just
witnessed you know it's pretty
spot-on listen man it was so crazy i got
calls out of the blue from everybody who
was involved with me writing the book
they were like
it's like you wrote this like you knew
it was gonna happen i was like man
i was will smith
that's all i can say
talking about empathy i mean first of
all
i did way worse than what will's done
okay you just didn't do it in front of a
hundred million people it just right it
just wasn't on camera but when you look
listen you know what because the thing
in the incident that you share in the
book what really tipped it over is when
is when the aggression was directed at
your wife not you that's what that's
what really set you off totally that i
mean and i was like
you're gonna die today
like i said it was overkill it was to
the point of like i could have killed
this guy
i mean put when you put somebody on
their head on the concrete
a lot of things can happen yeah and it
wasn't she just was shocked at the level
of violence so then what is
you know what is the the message with
will smith or like what do you take from
that or what is it that you want to say
about how that went down first of all
i'm going to tell you this and this is
this is the overall message for me is
that there was many many times
i was will smith
but the time that saved me was the time
i was chris rod
and my agent put his hands
literally grabbed my nuts
in a crowded party a hollywood party
again it's if it's no different than the
vanity fair party or anything or a big
hollywood event adam sandler's party
the head of the motion picture
department at william morris endeavor
this guy adam bennett gets high i don't
know what he's on first of all i know
drunk this wasn't drunk
he's licking his tongue out at me he's
acting all crazy i'd never met him
before i heard about him
uh he's the last slice the loans agent
he's eddie murphy's agent he's sandler's
agent he's head of the motion picture
department head morris the man
okay the number one agency in the world
and he comes over to me and i'm like i
stick my hand out like how you doing he
grabs my nuts
and with my wife right next to me in a
crowded party and bert baker basically
i'm the only black guy in the party by
the way everybody else is
hollywood royalty
right
i pushed him back like what are you
doing man i'll push him into other
people it's so crowded i'm like get away
from me man what do you hey
he's laughing he comes back again i push
him again and i'm like
what are you doing what the [ __ ] are you
doing
i'm getting angry just thinking about it
all over again
and he starts to laugh
now now i think
is there other people in on this like
here i am
the only black man in this party
and other people over there
other people saw it
there are people who would never say
anything but they were right there
and they were all looking like
and i thought they were in on it you
start to think
am i the joke here
y'all making like was this planned
because it's just too bizarre is this
jackass or something
and y'all think this [ __ ] is funny
and i said i'm gonna kill this dude now
that's the next thought
i was gonna put my fist through this
guy's head
and all of a sudden i went
i don't have to do that
i don't have to do that anymore
and i looked at my wife and you talking
about years of therapy already
where
you got to understand in the black
community
if someone was to call you [ __ ]
the rule is to destroy them like punch
them fight them don't because if you
don't you
quote unquote
let them do it
so
the whole rule
is that but but once you examine that
whole thing
i had to examine it and i said but there
are no [ __ ]
there's no such thing
am i a [ __ ]
no
so
it's not an insult in fact i can just
let it go
and count it to ignorance
the problem is and where the real
problem would lie is if i really felt
i was of true [ __ ]
all the insecurities
all that stuff would pop up and then i
would attack
same thing here
i'm not interested in this dude
this is not anything i want
so why would i get even get up why would
i have to kill this man
but i did have to do something
and i remember looking at my wife and
she said
she looked at me
i grabbed her hand and we left the party
we got in the car now mindset i'm trying
to tell you i had a thought of driving
right back through the club
like terminator you know what i mean
but i went home and i couldn't believe
i was degraded
dehumanized
it was emasculation of the highest
degree because here this was
my own agency
and then i didn't know who was in on it
like that was another thing i was like
is this
sandler's thing is this
you know i mean you know your mind just
starts to race yeah like what is
happening here
that's an assault what's what's
interesting i mean look we all we all
read about this and are aware of kind of
what happened on some level but in the
book like i don't know how many pages
you devote to it it's like 15 pages i
mean you go through the whole thing and
i learned much more about how it all
transpired
and
and one of the really interesting
aspects of this story is like not
knowing who to trust like
can i tell my manager can i tell this
other agents at the same agency what is
the head of the agency going to say or
do or not do and this is all you know
basically the peril with which
you have to you know figure out what the
right moves are because your your career
and your future is on the line depending
upon what you say or don't say but think
about the academy awards
chris was all by himself
nobody ran over to him
he was standing there totally beat up
face still red
still stinging
and no one went over to him
they went to will
they went over there with the world and
said are you okay are you all right
no one checked on chris
that's where i was
i'm sure chris was like
who do i trust now
where am i what the hell was that
but imagine
had chris bought back
it would have descended into chaos oh my
god it had been the end
of hollywood as we know it yeah and i
think he saved everything see
that was that measure of composure for
him to even joke about it for him to
just keep his cool
and just relax
in that moment i thought
that's
tough
like that's the essence
of true
toughness
again the joke should he have said it no
i don't think i i it was a bad joke
it wasn't even funny but he didn't
deserve that yeah he didn't deserve that
at all
and but i can tell you this
i
was will at one time were you out of
control
and wait all that had to do that was
going on in will
like that was going on in his you saw
there was more going on there
than that joke oh of course you know i
mean it was like i mean
it's like the zapruder film you could
break this thing down oh you know look
at it
like
all that stuff that's going down i
didn't beat that guy down for
disrespecting my wife it was something
else
you don't pick a guy up and slam on the
head on his head on the concrete
for that
it was something in me didn't have
anything to do with him
and there's many many times i would just
smack people and do stuff because i had
this inner anger
that
i did not control and
it's so vicious and so crazy and
insidious and and it sneaks up on you
at the lead like i promise you will did
not plan that out of course not okay
it's like it's like a going into a
blackout blacked out and you said you
and you knew when he was like get you
know my wife's name oh your [ __ ]
mouth i mean we were all like holy
this dude has lost he's having a
meltdown
but i knew that guy that was me you
couldn't calm me down after stuff like
this
and this is where my wife had to come
and say look man
if you ever do this man
and see
then i have to tell everybody because
what was wild because in my community in
black community they were like you
should have knocked the guy out sure
that's the rule and you know you're
you're like the the prototype alpha how
could this happen to you i mean two
million takes on this whole thing but
but can i tell you ask you this
would you have believed my story
had i knocked the guy out
i don't think anybody would
i just you're at a party terry crews
knocks out the head of the motion
picture department uh because he what
terry probably had some drinks yeah he
probably didn't listen i don't drink
they'd be like oh no
yeah right
yeah you just decided maybe they did
something you didn't like but there's
that mean thug terry we've been waiting
on
because i got a whole record of you
beating up people
yeah conversely
what would have happened had will smith
walked on stage and just said hey chris
you know i love you but that was that
was out of line you know and just
handled it with composure
he would have been
this unbelievable hero imagine if he had
to put it in his acceptance speech right
like what
chris said about my wife man
you know it was over the line
but i'm here to accept my acceptance and
it would have been a hero right but let
me tell you what hollywood's about and
this is where me and hollywood have
always been at odds
the head of the motion picture the head
of william morris endeavor
told me he could get away with it
i had a private meeting with him
it's all in the book
and i said hey man you don't get to
molest the clients and go to work the
next day
he said yes he can
and he said what i'm going to do is take
his title and suspend him for 30 days
and i said man hey man you going to give
him a vacation
what are you talking about you can't
molest the clients
what do you do
dude it was the same as the standing
ovation for will
and i went
i said dude what are you talking about i
handed him a letter i grabbed his letter
that he wrote
demanding that mel gibson be kicked out
of hollywood he wrote it for the
huffington po huffington post for
anti-semitic remarks i said look
you said mel's gibson needs to be kicked
out of hollywood forever
for these remarks but anti-semitic
remarks as reprehensible as they are
they are not illegal
what your man did is a crime
and you're telling me
it's different
he said
it's different terry
i couldn't believe it dude i
i just said and that's the rule see
the rules of hollywood is call it out
until it happens to you
you know i mean
cancel anybody else but us no
no not at all
because we admit well well and then you
pursue
you file criminal charges even knowing
like that's probably not going to go
anywhere and then the civil suit
which ultimately doesn't look like it's
going to go anywhere until a couple
other dudes come out of the woodwork
that's right and then it's a whole
different thing a whole different story
and some females
guys and girls it was crazy
and uh
but if i hadn't gone public it would
have never
i it would have never brought the real
the people out and they wanted to join
my case
privately without
you know saying their names i don't
think i respected that
but the thing was is that they were
willing to go to the mat
for this guy
and it it was so foul
and so corrupt
because you gotta understand about
hollywood i mean like harvey weinstein
would lead
you know all this
women in hollywood parties at his house
while he was raping them
you know and this is the thing you're
talking
about what
one reason i wrote the book
was that i noticed that there was things
where
success is the warmest place to hide
you know it's a great place because you
you don't no one calls you on your [ __ ]
no one because you're the man
you're will smith
you're
you're the head of the motion picture
department
and
when what we need because we talk about
values we can say values but unless you
actually
act on those values it means nothing
ultimately money and power rule and in
the case of
this adam bennett thing
it wasn't until uh money and power were
threatened that you were actually able
to move the needle and
um what's interesting is that typically
in these cases then it then becomes
about how can we discredit
the person going after us yeah but
because you had
done all that inside work and kind of
owned up publicly and privately to the
stuff that they would have been able to
hang over you yeah there was a freedom
with that right where you were like come
at me
that was
again when you're talking about
gratitude
i'm beyond thankful
for that d-day
for that moment when i saw myself as i
really was
because if i hadn't like you you could
ask me like where do you think you'd be
oh my god
you know running hiding
um
imagine i would have had no strength to
do anything to even come up against
something like that
had i had secrets like that because they
would have found stuff well and had you
not unpacked those secrets you would
have cold cocked the guy
right and but you might not have even
been at that party to begin with but you
see we can keep going you know i mean
it's kind of like it could have been
over before that it could have been
where but where the question really is
is where would the fall have come
that's really what we're talking about
like what would have taken me out
you know because all of this any of this
deception that i was living was going to
take me out some way shape or form right
and um
let me tell you man i i
that's where gratitude comes in for me
right now because i'm just like oh if i
hadn't done that
and i just thank god so i'm just
thankful for my wife i'm thankful for my
family
i'm thankful for the people who did
stick with me
because it was a very lonely time during
that period there were camps and people
were like
what is terry talking about and
in my own community i was looked at as a
pariah for even
technically joining me too
which they thought was a female thing
until all these men i mean we had
wrestlers and
pro athletes that came out about
you know the fact is
there's a organization called one in six
that talks about how one in six men
have been sexually molested at some time
in their life and wait and don't even
acknowledge it they've been in
military and whatever and they they just
called it well the guy was goofing
around
but you've been molested yeah
that line was crossed you don't you
don't unpack that and and deal with that
you're going to act out in some way that
is not in service to you or others
the prison is full
full of people who were at one time or
another used and abused in that way
and acted out in some way but would
never ever tell what happened to them
and because
i mean that's why you know you doing
what you've done is is so powerful and
palpable because you are the you're
you're cut from this cloth of the
ultimate you know you've got this
incredible physique and this incredible
career
and and and as such for you to be able
to come to the microphone and talk about
these things i think gives permission to
all of these people who are harboring
these stories with shame and in secrecy
i'll tell you this when i will say my
greatest
accomplishment
beyond film beyond movies and tv and all
this stuff
was when i got to team up with amanda
nguyen
and she is the founder of rise which was
all about
um
[Music]
passing the sexual assault survivors
bill of rights because the thing is is
that the whoever the perpetrator is has
tons of rights
and she found that the the anyone who
was a victim of these things
had no rights at all
and um i joined up with her and we went
to congress
and what was wild is that she had always
bring brought women there to talk and it
was never a big it never got that much
light and by having a man there
that
it was packed that room was full
it was on cnn it was the highlight
people were like wait a minute
and i look at that and i i could feel
the millions and millions of people who
never got to tell
dude it was
i don't even know how to describe it
because it's something that
it it comes with so much shame
you know societal shame and
and but
i said i have nothing to be ashamed of
and i remember this was my
my log line during this whole time i was
like i will not be shamed
i did nothing wrong and i had to repeat
that
because you feel like oh people don't
even want to touch it they were like oh
i said i would not be shamed i did
nothing wrong
and this is what happens
to people who are victim or victimized
i am no longer a victim i feel like now
you know there's a point where you you
grow past and you decide to grow and you
decide to move
i was victimized but not but no longer
and um
but to just be there and feel that from
so many people that energy
was like finally finally someone could
come forward and say this
it was my calling and i said this is the
most important thing i'll ever do yeah
ever yeah that's really beautiful
um
you've been very generous with your time
and i want to let you go but i can't let
you go without one final
thing that i want to
talk with you about which is this quote
that i love
um that i've heard you say
which is
in order to have you must do
and in order to do you must be
there's so much in there man like this
is this this is the keys to the kingdom
it is my opinion it is all right so
let's close it out with a few thoughts
on what that means
how that idea has been transformative in
your life you know
i'm i am an idealist
um
and i think it comes with being an
artist or just seeing the vision
and just
seeing a better way and going oh i want
to go i want that you know
um
the thing is is that
for me
what was wild is that i always thought
things weren't possible or i thought it
was magic you know
but what i began to do
is
in order to be the person i wanted to be
i had to say like
i have it already like i had to to in
order to be
to have the money and be a let's say
consider yourself a rich person
you have to look at the riches you have
and say
i have this
you know and to enter into order to have
you must do and then once you say i have
this you do the things
a rich person would do
and all of a sudden you are
but but remember
that when in my mom's religion the do
part was gone
it was gone
and i realized that in the action
first of all the visualization
and then the action
and then there it is it comes
and it's almost it's almost like like i
said you're you're in
you don't know you're in los angeles but
you are you know you're you're
so nobody somebody just closed your eyes
blindfolded you plopped you right there
in it
you all of a sudden
would have to know like you know you
would have markers and different things
all this stuff but
the realization is that you are there
and you have to be there now
and then you behave like you're there
now right
dude
it's a deep thought yeah yeah you own
that truth
it just hasn't happened yet like my
friend jesse hitler has a he has a quote
that he used to a mantra that he would
repeat to himself when he was a young
person like i'm a millionaire they just
haven't paid me yet but like
you know that idea applying to
everything like i you know you just you
you intuit or you inhabit the idea of
what that
who that person is who has the thing
that you want or is living the life that
you want and you then conduct yourself
accordingly let me tell you and that
perfect example is the first time i
tried to quit porn
you're like this is the hardest thing
ever like what am i going to do
i remind you i had three different jobs
i started working like crazy because i
was like what am i doing my time
you know yeah and but i was it was hard
because i was like this was what i used
to do
and when i didn't do it anymore
the habit for doing something had you
you don't you don't get rid of things
you just replace them
and i started to replace it with good
things and all of a sudden
i didn't have any desire for it anymore
but
i can't mark the moment
i can't mark the time it was 12 years
but then all of a sudden you go i don't
need that that's not me anymore i'm a
whole nother person
and it's so incredible it's almost like
going back through those franklin
planners
and realizing wait you saw yourself
there
you you're even past that
you know what i mean yeah but it's also
the difference between
white knuckling it like i'm gonna apply
my self-will
to this problem and and just like i am
not gonna do this thing versus like i'm
letting go i'm transcending this because
i am becoming this other person who
wouldn't do that let me tell you and
that that is a great saying because i
have to tell you this because
willpower doesn't work
it doesn't work believe me i tried the
first time i was getting out of it
you're like
no it's ridiculous but what i realized
is that it's not a willpower issue
it's a lack of information issue
the more you start to realize and know
it changes you
i like when you know what it's doing
when you know what it's costing
you know i did things like
making logs of how much i spent
on all that every day
and you think if you didn't write it
down you go i spent 20 bucks
it when i actually wrote it down it was
300
and you go what
in the world but you
we don't we you can't rely on our
intuition that way you have to start to
really write it down see it and the
whole thing and
the willpower does not work it's got to
be the info the info
what do what is it i don't know
and once you start going like that you
know what you're trying to lose what you
know what to eat you know what causes
you
to do these things you know
you know what exercises to do you know
what to be and it's so
and it often it changes you you wake up
and you're just different because you
know more and you're responsible for
more the more you know the more you're
responsible for it and so it makes it an
amazing i like to call it
it moves from a toilet
into a tornado
the spin just starts to go up and up and
up enough you know the toilet is the
other way you know
but the tornado it gets better and
better and better
that's great i love it man i love it uh
any final thoughts on somebody who might
be listening to this or watching this
who is caught in
some form of compulsion or addictive
behavior and is having trouble knowing
they need to put it in the rear view
mirror but can't seem to get out of
their own way let me tell you um
my best advice period
is
find someone you love
and trust
and really really believe in
and tell them
most
addictions thrive in secrecy
that's it i'm telling you it's the
secret is the killer
once you know i went public
on facebook live yeah
that's they've done like hundreds of
millions of views now at this point oh
my god
worldwide when i did that the world
shook
um but i did that
to be to to kill it to kill it for good
shame can't survive the light it can't
it's like exposing the germs to sunlight
and dude
fine but see i wouldn't say and i would
never
never never suggest that you do this
publicly
do it
with people you don't trust usually it
doesn't work out it does no
i was built for that
i was in that mode but actually i'd
already been through
past that point and i went public just
even to to help other people but
i went when i got public with my family
and i got public when i i started the
voice that i had an addiction i started
to voice
what the pornography thing was and i
start to talk
it it loses its power
slowly but surely the fact that you can
talk about your alcoholism
it it takes the power away from it
and
so anyone who's going through this
the more you find someone you trust that
you can share these things with it
slowly starts to real it's just
i like to say it shrinks
and it gets cleaned out
but
the the secrecy man oh
everything grows in secret dude yeah
everything you you lose total control
the more secrets you keep
that's one reason why i'm so vulnerable
because i don't want i don't want any
secrets i just don't i i don't want any
more i tell the whole story
and man i'm in control right i feel
totally the ultimate weight loss yes it
is yes it is
you want to feel lighter in your skin it
feels so good man i i like to call it
being one person remember it was the
image terry and then it was back with
you
there's no nothing feels better than
being one person
like i mean when i say i say what i mean
it's so refreshing and i have no there's
no guilt there's no it's like like being
debt-free right
you know what i mean it just feels like
no i don't owe anybody yeah feels good
yeah
um amazing man thank you oh thank you
appreciate you terry crews that was
unbelievable oh what a gift i enjoy this
thank you man it's great joy thank you
for having me um of course everybody
pick up terry's new book tough available
wherever you buy books and terry's
pretty easy to find on the internet
track down uh if you haven't heard of
him i'm sure you already have um and
also america's got talent coming back
this summer that's right this summer may
31st 31st all right so he'll be in your
household worldwide that's it and uh i'm
going to get [ __ ] because like you were
here for over two hours and we didn't
even talk about the fitness stuff
or intermittent fasting or anything like
that so i might have to
yeah yeah do your best uh
you know do a five-minute workout that's
what you gotta do there you go
good times appreciate you thank you
thank you my man peace
[Music]
you